shouting at us nazis and that we're
provoking the situation
we're not far from sharim the heartbeat
of the ultra-orthodox community here in
jerusalem now we were forced out of
there with people shouting at us
this community is at the center of a row
over
lockdown measures recently thousands of
ultra-orthodox mourners many of them
without masks
took to these streets to attend the
funerals of two rabbis
it caused an outcry in israel and wasn't
the first time
as the country struggles to deal with
its handling of the coronavirus
the society is becoming more and more
divided
many people in jerusalem do not support
the behavior
of the ultra-orthodox neighbours i don't
know exactly the statistics about the
ultraducks
ultra orthodox community but i do know
that under 65 the statistic says that
one out of every 10
000 people dies in corona that's a very
very small number i actually think that
the bigger problem is the fact that the
government over here
is uh is making it convincing everyone
to take this vaccine that no one has any
ideas about and no one
understands me that long-term side
effects about
i think anyone who doesn't put on a mask
is like a murderer
it is against all the rules of the rabbi
all the rabbis are against it
these are the people who don't have
communication they don't have television
and they simply don't know what this
disease is they don't believe it they
don't blame the coronavirus they blame
the hospitals
i can't understand it the level that
people can believe conspiracy theories
the israeli government has voted to
extend the current lockdown until friday
it's double fines and it's keeping the
airport
shut it's becoming an increasing
nightmare for the police to control
those who refuse to adhere to lockdown
measures
we requested a comment from the police
but they declined to comment
at the same time the ultra-orthodox
community
says it's feeling persecuted
the hatred doesn't lead to anything good
in the world there are a few rabbis who
think
i don't belong to them they think the
coronavirus is imaginary
this is what they think this blow from
having the lockdown is god giving us
clues
he's hinting to us that we have to fix
something
while there are cause for israel to be
divided into different covert 19
zones the country's prime minister says
the lockdown rules apply to everyone
regardless of their religion
the ultra-orthodox community comprises
some 15 percent of the population
but according to the health ministry it
also represents more than
35 of coronavirus cases
the latest word from the government is
that the current
nationwide lockdown may not be israel's
last
policy rt jerusalem